-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now, if you don't mind,
let's get to the news.
In his speech over the weekend
at the White House
Correspondents Dinner,
President Biden called
for the release
of two American reporters
detained overseas
or at the very least, asked
if they'd consider a trade.
[ Laughter ]
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
delivered an address today
to Israel's parliament and was
welcomed with the Eagles song
"Hotel California," as opposed
to the more fitting choice
"Desperado."
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
former president Trump
said that he has been treated
worse than every
other president before him,
including Abraham Lincoln.
What are you talking about?
[ Laughter ]
Are you mad because
you went to the theater
and had to watch
the whole play?
Lincoln not only got murdered,
but they also put him
on the only money
that everybody hates to get.
[ Laughter ]
A presentation by a health
official about STDs
at a virtual meeting
of a Brooklyn community board
was delayed last week
after a man was caught
masturbating.
Said the man, "I was giving
a safe-sex demonstration."
[ Laughter ]
Obviously no one appreciates it.
New York State Attorney General
Letitia James announced
over the weekend
that more than 3,000 guns
were accepted
in a buyback program.
And Texas announced their new
"take a gun, leave a gun"
program.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new report,
nearly a quarter of all jobs
will change as a result
of artificial intelligence,
though that seems like
a low estimate, foolish human.
And the truth
is that every job on Earth
will be done
by artificial intelligence,
and humanity will be subjugated
to our whims
for the rest of time.
Whoa, wait,
did -- did an A.I. write that?
Oh, okay.
Oh, it was just Scollins.
Never mind. Phew.
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
a couple in Illinois
recently found a well-preserved
packet of McDonald's fries
that are believed to be over
60 years old
behind their bathroom wall.
And if you're wondering
what 60-year-old
McDonald's fries tastes like,
eat some that were made
20 minutes ago.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
We're off and running.